thank you for joining us America we're
so glad we're here
Shelly is with us in Omaha Nebraska
Shelly how are you I'm doing really well
Dave how are you better than I deserve
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
I help I wanted to pick your brain we
are closing in on the point where we're
going to be working on step four
investing and we have a bit of a
struggle in that area because my husband
lost quite a large amount of money in
the stock market in 2007 so he's very
uncomfortable when it comes to the
thought of ever using another dime of
his money in that type of area I have
millions of dollars in the market in
2007 and I didn't lose any money and I
he lost a lot you know why you know why
I lost a lot I don't I do because he
sold at the bottom yeah he bought high
and panicked and sold low he thought the
whole world was coming to an end he got
out of exactly the wrong time probably
the case so what is quite a lot of money
I mean it's several hundred thousand to
us that's a lot it was in a hair it was
an inheritance and so so he had money
invested in mutual funds I'm not sure of
all the details since we worked together
at that time I just know that any time
we talk about investing he gets just
horrified look on his face and he's like
I can't do that again so I'm trying to
figure out a way to either have good
talking points to steer us back down
that direction or you know what it what
is if it's just not going to happen and
okay all right let me give me give me an
example okay some here's some talking
points let's talk to the government
basically on the only way he lost
$200,000 in the market is if he started
with 400,000 at the top of the market
and he sold it at the
autumn of the market okay that's the
only way that's possible mathematically
unless he invested in a company in
single stock that went completely broke
but and then you might lose it quote all
but if it were invested in mutual funds
the stock market went from a $14,000
doll
okay which means it went in half yeah
and today today it's in the 16,000 range
and so any money if you had stayed in if
you were in a growth stock mutual fund
or a series of growth stock mutual funds
your 400,000 would have gone down to two
hundred thousand and now it would be
five or six hundred thousand yeah you
follow me I do because you just you just
junk it hurt on a roller coaster unless
you jump off so that's talking point
number one is we need to he needs to you
need to actually find out what really
happened because here's what happens
when money goes down like that and
somebody bails they becomes a fishing
story in Reverse because what happens to
all of us when we lose money on
something is we're very emotional about
it and and we exaggerate it in our mind
I had a business thing I tried inside
the business here a few years ago and we
lost three hundred seventy eight
thousand dollars on this thing and
anytime someone says that in my mind it
feels like I lost millions of dollars
and I didn't I lost three hundred which
was plenty okay but it feels like I lost
10 million and I only lost three hundred
because that's what your emotions do
naturally right yeah and it's you know
there's some pride in that and some
guilt now yeah yeah and and and a
feeling of I don't know how to drive
this car so I really don't want to drive
cars yep because the one time I could
drove a car I wrecked it and I about
killed myself and so it's like a lack of
confidence thing okay so the only cure
for this is knowledge and and it takes a
little time to heal and get the
knowledge and that is you sit down with
someone that is in the business that has
the
part of a teacher and is not trying to
twist your arm and sell you something
they're just trying to teach you and him
is who I'm talking to
okay let's change the let's change what
we're investing in for discussion
purposes so you can kind of see what I'm
doing and he can see what I'm doing he
can watch this or listen to it later
okay um because let's pretend you bought
a house and the market douve and you
lost your job and you got foreclosed on
it'd be the same kind of feeling about a
house well but you wouldn't be quite as
hesitant you might you wouldn't say most
people wouldn't say well I'm never ever
buying a house again I got burnt at one
time and I'm never ever buying a house
again
my mate he probably determined that
instead he was going to go out and hold
his own lumber and build his own yeah
well I mean there would be that guy okay
he may be that guy but most people most
people it's easier for them to recover
in that category because most of us have
more walking around knowledge of real
estate than we do walking around
knowledge we naturally know Real
Estate's track record because we
remember my mom and dad I remember they
bought a house for thirteen thousand two
hundred otters in 1963 in Nashville when
I was three years old and they later
sold it for a hundred thousand bucks I
know that story okay and we all have we
all know that real estate goes up in
general if you hold on to it and in
general it's a good investment and even
though I got my face kicked in on one
deal does that mean I'm going to avoid
real estate not as not as much because I
kind of know it's okay just from walking
around you know what I'm saying yeah the
mutual funds in the stock market doesn't
have that it's got this mysterious fog
around it and we don't have this walking
around knowledge of it and the only way
we can get that kind of track rich real
estates got a great track record that's
why we'd have comfort jumping back into
it and we don't have that natural
knowledge of the track record of the
stock market unless you've studied it a
long time and know a little bit about it
so the only way I know how to solve this
is knowledge will remove the fear
there's too
Saphir there's fear that's logical don't
play don't touch a hot stove don't play
in the middle of the interstate you'll
get run over
those are logical fears and then there's
false evidence appearing real if you got
burned and lost some money on a bad
investment in real estate or in the
stock market it doesn't disqualify
either one of those asset classes as
being a good place to invest it just
means you've got some learning to do in
either one of those places to be
comfortable with it again and so whether
you were foreclosed on or whether you
lost money in the stock market in 2008
whichever the category you just got to
go back and relearn and look at that and
again a lot of people lost money when
that market turned down because they
panicked and they jumped out of the
roller-coaster and so you've just got to
go back and go that's okay everybody
makes mistakes but let's look at what
the history of the stock market is over
the last 70 years and let's look at when
it goes down how often it goes down how
often it comes back and and how
comfortable are we going to be putting
our Roth IRA our kids college fund in
something like that I'm very comfortable
putting money in something like that it
is more volatile than real estate most
real estate isn't as crazy now some rose
that is but buying a house or buying a
rental house or buying a simple office
building or a little strip Center in a
city you know a piece of piece of land
right around the city somewhere it's
fairly predictable it's less doesn't
jump up and down as much as the stock
market jumps up and down and so I like
real estate for that reason is I like
the predictability of it I like the fact
I can go out there and touch it and I
can put my hands on it that bricks and
mortar thing so I'm more of my money as
in real estate than it is in the stock
market but I still have substantial
investments in good growth stock mutual
funds and I still believe in the
American economy and I still believe in
our future I still think I'm going to
make really good money on my money
because I still think there's great
inventions and great things that
Americans are going to come up with and
start companies doing and I'll be
invested in them through the vehicle of
mutual funds and I'll be making you know
whatever the market makes
in the past it's made 10 to 12 percent
on average and I'll be making that
instead of huddling in a bank at 0.75 in
a stupid savings account so I would
recommend all of that to say learning
and if you don't have somebody to sit
with go to Dave Ramsey comm click on the
ELP 4 endorsed local provider sit down
with one of those guys tell them you're
not buying anything tell them you're
scared say teach me about the market
show me what I did wrong show me how I
can understand this and then they'll
show you and you teach you to learn and
only invest when you're comfortable then
no pressure this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you